all right let's bring in uh the minister
for local government and the supporter
of liz trust it's paul scully paul
scully good morning
with us pick up on what you heard from
your colleague there mark harper yeah i
don't think the those sort of uh
language of you know electoral suicide
and all these kind of things is helpful
in any way i mean we it's important that
we remain really positive on what we are
doing each team are doing now marco i
really respect mark is a real detailed
guy but he clearly hasn't read the full
ft article when liz was talking about
you know we'll see what more we can do
should it but the premise that she was
talking about in that article was that
it's absolutely right rather than taking
money from people and then giving it
back to them as a handout just don't
take it in the first place which is why
she's talking about reversing the ni um
increase and and looking at tax cuts in
that way but clearly um also i think
what this whole debate has done it
forgets about the 37 billion pounds
worth of support that's already in place
that's coming on stream at the moment
it's already started a number of people
have seen the first of their 650 pounds
coming into their onto their bills but
they are on their um bank accounts but
they will also get support directly from
their bills come september and so that's
what we're going to be reviewing in an
emergency budget by the end of september
i mean we know that 37 billion is
probably it's going to be inadequate to
cover the cost that we're facing but
we'll come on to that in a moment so you
think that mark harper has perhaps
misinterpreted over-interpreted because
that's been the accusations that the liz
trusters has made these policy
announcements and then the journalists
have misinterpreted over interpreted
them so mark harper's doing the same
thing i got it wrong well i think if you
look at ft articles she was really clear
she was just talking about the fact that
the conservative way of supporting
people is
is not to take the money in the first
place but she did also go on to say i
say it's all there in the fd article and
that she'll look at what needs to be
done and um and that's why this is why
is michael i i don't know the problem is
when you are running campaigns are
through social media you tend to look at
headlines and it's always uh there's a
details about it
that's what i'm saying i think in this
occasion i think the uh uh you know
we've we've gone
a little bit ott in terms of the the
approach in this i'd rather both camp
just concentrate on what they are doing
um and yes scrutinize the others that's
fine but we've got to keep within the
tram lines of remembering that uh we are
one party albeit broad church there are
political differences at the moment and
uh and this is philosoph philosophical
differences do we have more of the same
or do we have a bold ambitious policy to
grow our economy support people now in
the immediate future don't forget liz
was the first person to talk about
cutting the uh the green levees on on um
their energy bills to help people in the
more immediate time uh pausing those
green libraries because we will still
want to transition
so it's going to pick you up absolutely
we still want it we still want to
transition to to net zero clearly but
but we don't want to do it on the pack
on the back of the most vulnerable who
are seeing their energy bills go through
the roof as you rightly say yeah i mean
look a lot of people are watching this
and seeing this fighting this blue one
blue fighting will be really concerned
and it speaks a little bit what mark
harper was saying earlier the fact that
you guys can't even sit around the table
to try and work out how to deal with
this crisis that the country is facing
why can't liz and rishi and boris
johnson and whoever else needs to be in
a room right now working out what to do
when those prices go up well look i
think you've seen that they have done
this over the last few years and uh you
know it joined covid what we saw during
covert and bearing in mind with all the
argument the debate that we just had
the the during cover what we did is we
put measures in place it started off i
think the first budget was 12 billion
pounds we ended up putting 408 billion
pounds out to support the economy and it
was all based on what was happening at
the time it was it was responding and
reacting and flexing at the given time
not just
this is the thing because we know it's
going to go up 650 maybe more yeah be
proactive get in the room put people's
minds at ease well not i think do that
yeah i think what's happening tomorrow
at the moment is that a lot of the
support that 37 billion pounds that i
was talking about is being rolled out
literally as we speak i was on the phone
to councils just last week asking them
to make sure they can speed up handing
out the council tax rebates um to people
especially those that are not paying by
direct debit so all that work is still
going on we've got a load of work coming
on next month
when people will see money coming off
their energy bills as a direct response
to that 37 billion pounds but that gives
us time then to see exactly where we're
going with the energy price cap and
respond in the emergency budget which is
only in a few weeks time a few weeks
time is a lot you know if people are
struggling to get a couple of quids to
put in the meter they want to know now
what they're going to be dealing with
you know there's a huge campaigners in
their pool to try and not pay your
energy bills on the first of october if
you got ahead of this then that campaign
might lose all but as i say this is why
we need to communicate exactly what we
are doing so we've got the warm you know
warm um homes payment we've got the
walmart homes discount uh we've got the
cold weather payments we've got uh uh
all those measures four pensioners
directly that will be coming on on
stream we've got the if um when liz
reverses the
national insurance levies that will give
um average taxpayers 240 pounds more
most the lowest paid will be getting
1200 pounds uh support at the moment
around 1200 pounds pretty well every
household will be getting 600 pounds so
that's a significant chunk it might not
be as much as as you say as required
which is why first of all the tax cuts
the extra tax cuts by um by reversing
the ni levies etc in that emergency
budget will help but also as liz has
rightly said by um by pausing those uh
those green um levies on energy bills
and seeing what more needs to be done at
the given time when we know the figures
that's the important thing we need to
know the exact figures to be able to
know what the response is we'll know
that from the 26th of august so we'll
have you back and hopefully you'll be
able to tell us what the thing will be
all right let's move on a slightly
different topic because it's something
that you have seen in a couple of the
papers for the past few days um one of
your colleagues nadine doris is
describing what's happening with the
privileges committee the investigation
to whether boris johnson lights
parliament as a witch hunt is it a witch
hunt
no no i think uh again it just needs to
go through its parliamentary process um
you know that's that's all set out uh
whether you like the process or not uh
let's let's let's face it you know we've
we've got tripped over by parliamentary
process around privileged committee and
other other um committees we're looking
at the conduct of um of of mps whether
it's the prime minister or not over the
last few years and so there is a process
let's just get through the process and i
think that's the appropriate thing do
you think he likes to parliament uh no i
don't um and uh you know i i think the
whole point about having all of these
reports et cetera metropolitan police
investigation were to find out the facts
and then that was uh what was put in
front of parliament to decide so there's
no no way that he willfully uh
misled parliament in in my view i mean
no way in your view but we are going to
go through well that's that's what the
process is therefore to say i can't see
how they're going to find otherwise but
i mean like that but there's a process
but there's but i'm but i'm not on the
but i'm not on the committee so i don't
see we've heard the words he said we
said he said that he didn't know that
there were parties going on to the best
of his knowledge and you know that
turned out not to be true because he was
fined yeah but that's what i'm talking
about willfully misleading parliament
and there's a really specific thing
because otherwise if you're talking
about misleading parliament then uh uh
you know think
situations change
all all the time and you'll get most but
most politicians sit there and you know
when events happen that will say one
thing at one time
and then a year two years later
something like something else would
happen to to
put that off
of off kilter in this in this context as
i say
the prime minister did what he thought
was right um clearly as i say sue grey
made her report metropolitan police came
in they um
they they decided otherwise a lot of
this was on um
uh you know fair hairline decisions in
terms if you look at someone like richie
sunak with the way he was fined compared
to kierstama's um situation in durham
they're not actually what exactly
they're not that different but the
the metropolitan police came to
different decisions in different areas
and that's fine that was their
that's exactly what they were charged to
do the metropolitan
your major point very clear just finally
then you would have heard david this
morning uh talking about water company
bosses having their bonuses stopped
until they deal with the leaks that the
water companies uh are apparently not
dealing with properly are you in support
of that idea what i'm in support of is
uh you know i'm not gonna make the thing
about their bonuses that's for their
companies to sort out but it's not they
should but it's not a good look it's not
a good look for water company uh bosses
to be taking big bonuses if they are not
investing sufficiently in the
infrastructure it's not right
that um the ordinary customers are doing
their bit for environments we're just
talking a little bit about green levees
and and climate change if they're doing
everything they can to conserve water to
conserve energy to do their bit for
climate change
the water companies need to invest a lot
a lot more in water maintenance and
leakages across the country paul scully
good to talk to you this morning thanks
for being with us thank you